you're the host of the emmys this year
what is the game plan
is everyone going to be home where are
you going to be what
what is the deal i'll be at the staples
center and the reason they chose the
staples center
is because it's huge and they feel like
they can
spread what the skeleton crew that we
will have there
they can spread everybody out this will
be life
most of the nominees and presenters will
be at home
i think they're going to have 140 live
feeds going at once wow
nothing can go wrong yeah the technical
aspect of this is really what what
concerns me and it's something i i have
no control over but
you know there's nothing funny about
losing a wi-fi signal you know it's just
like
it's just suddenly there's nothing so
i'm hoping everything works that's and
you know we have to rely not just on our
own signal there
at the staples center but on each
person's individual
uh internet connection at their house or
wherever they are
so that's something but uh for the most
part
with a couple of exceptions i will be
alone
in a very very big stadium
that's what will be happening that's the
plan all right so you'll be alone
do you really have a good handle at this
point because they're only a couple of
days away
or are you still a little bit vague on
how this whole thing's gonna work
i have a pretty good handle on it yeah
it's just a matter of if it does work
and also whether it can be entertaining
not seeing people on a red carpet and
not watching not having an
audience not any of that stars there all
that [ __ ]
geez i don't want it to feel like a
three-hour zoom meeting that's my if i
have one goal that's it
so in your mind how can you combat it
turning into a three-hour zoom meeting
well i just have to dip into my bag of
many talents
you know i'll be um i'll be singing and
dancing and
juggling and doing all the stuff that
that i do
you know will people hold the actual
emmy statue when they win
is there a way to do that you have a
plan for that too
for some of the categories we're going
to be delivering
the emmys to their homes like if you win
there will be a knock on the door and
basically
postmates or doordash will show up with
your this is
somebody wearing a protective suit
idolized
basically